serious are you about doing music how
serious am I about doing work
what a weird question to get from the
darkness
I want to tell you something right now
that's pretty heavy moment right now you
know what I mean
sure I really can address that I'm you
know I'm gonna say a preliminary no uh
but let me mail it over over the show
but pretty sure we'll come back to the
initial no but I'll
I don't take the question lightly it was
very nice but
yeah man we're empty nesters we can
wherever we want it's a good time you
know what I mean we don't want anybody
else in the house you know what the
perfect reason is for me right now is if
my wife and I have sex and somebody else
cleans up around the house foreign